merci pour cette rentrée historique
d'être de plus en plus nombreux trucs de
fou et c'est vrai je pense que c'est
grâce au teint aller de Gilles Verdez
mais énormément à toutes les personnes
qui nous regardent merci avant en tout
cas d'être aussi nombreux à nous
regarder nombreux et nombreuses beaucoup
de monde autour de la table pour pas
grand chose
déjà es-tu heureuse
la radio tous les jours sur Europe 1 tu
viens d'arriver exactement c'est
important de le préciser en direct en
direct et oui tous les jours dans un
horaire très compliqué et tu es heureuse
bah écoute ça va mal démarré je prends
mes marques je me trompe encore un petit
peu de bouton on entend parler pendant
les pubs etc
voilà c'est du lundi au vendredi de 16 à
18h en direct sur Europe 1 s'appelle
Sophie et les copains puisque sophia a
des copains contrairement à moi
parce que j'aimais beaucoup à faire
conclue mais tu veux que je te dise si
j'avais été toi j'aurais pris la même
décision c'est vrai ça a été difficile
[Musique]
et un moment moi c'est ça que j'aime et
je voulais te dire j'aime les animateurs
Sophie Davant elle a plus rien à prouver
c'est vrai Sophie je te le dis tu étais
franchement il y a jeudi Évelyne Thomas
Sophie Davant et
flamant
et de prendre un risque comme ça alors
que l'émission cartonne je trouve ça
très fort et je te dis bravo parce que
au contraire là en plus
je te le dis je trouve que c'est quand
même un gros animation cette tranche de
deux heures à la radio c'est une mise en
danger tu t'es en direct c'est c'est
beaucoup plus dur je te dis la vérité
d'animé ce que tu fais de 16 à 18h sur
Europe 1 que voilà c'est sûr voilà et je
trouve que bravo à toi franchement c'est
vrai parce que c'est vrai que je dois
dire que j'ai pas mis endormi quand même
c'est trois quatre derniers mois non non
c'est difficile à prendre une décision
pareil mais je me suis dit que ça
faisait six ans que je pense que j'avais
fait un peu le non pas le tour parce que
j'ai été pas blasé mais je pensais qu'on
avait atteint des scores d'audience des
des records et je me suis dit c'est
difficile de rester à ce niveau là 20%
donc moi je pense que tu as très bien
fait je te jure et pourtant j'adore
l'émission j'aimerais que je trouve
une mission mais je pense que c'est
voilà c'est moi j'adorais voilà moi je
dire la vérité le compte animé c'est ton
programme
je te dis à ce que je trouve que tu es
un naturel tu es une animatrice t'es pas
une présentatrice je pense qu'une
présentatrice peut faire l'émission sur
France 2 une animatrice ne peut une
présentatrice ne peut pas faire ce que
tu fais sur Europe 1 voilà donc vraiment
bravo mais c'est vrai que c'est ce que
je retrouve dans la radio sur Europe 1
je retrouve parce que je connaissais le
matin dans cette au programme a été du
direct
on parle de beaucoup de choses parce que
moi j'ai toujours fait des trucs où on
apprend quand même c'est pas juste du
divertissement j'aime qu'on apprenne des
infos donc je suis entourée de gens
incroyables cet après-midi elle va un
monsieur qui s'appelle Bill François qui
a fait normal sup qui a fait
Polytechnique et qui a fait une thèse
sur la physique des mouvements engendrés
par le déplacement des bandes poissons
[Rires]
un type qui sait tout sur tout le monde
aquatique
sur la faune la flore enfin un peu de
science et ce type là est drôle et donc
c'est l'un de mes copains et l'idée
c'est qu'il nous apprennent des tas de
trucs auxquels on penserait même pas
quoi ça c'est une émission de bande
comme on aime écouter Sophie sur Europe
1 de 16 et 18h plutôt regarder
et la capitale du Pakistan vrai ou faux
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous allez en faire de ces
1300 € Léa vous avez une petite idée oui
Sophie ça va être pour un voyage un
voyage vous connaissez la destination
non mais j'aimerais bien partir
justement en Écosse bon ben on vous
embrasse très fort Léa on est très
heureux pour vous que vous ayez remporté
ce jackpot à bientôt Léa peut-être merci
beaucoup
les copains l'idée c'est de prendre des
auditeurs en direct de jouer avec eux
mais que le jeu soit prétexte à
apprendre des choses à muscler un peu la
culture générale oh non mais je vois je
vois que tu t'éclates je pense que tu as
pris la bonne décision que je te jure
vite tu regretteras pas je pense que tu
es parti pour longtemps sur Europe 1 et
en téléthe tu as tout fait tu as fait
des prime time je vais faire encore de
la télé
sur le sur le sur l'émission de brocante
c'est super mais ça y est cloque comme
on dit chez nous ça y est tu l'as fait
ta cartonné ça y est combien combien
tu vas devenir un guéri dont stop
[Musique]
c'est un des gros événements de
l'actualité mercato média de l'été
comment est-ce que France Télévisions a
pris la nouvelle quand vous leur avez
annoncé et ce qu'ils ont tout fait pour
vous retenez
alors
d'abord moi je me suis sentie
extrêmement désirée par Constance
banquet et de
navigateurs
qui vous expliquent pourquoi ils
viennent vous chercher vous et qui
argumente et donc c'est flatteurs
ils m'ont dit que il voulait quelqu'un
de populaire dans le sens noble du terme
de proche des téléspectateurs des
auditeurs et puis quelqu'un de de
solaire bonne humeur
qui sait établir le lien comme ça et qui
est capable d'être entouré de complices
en animant justement que comme vous
l'avez dit
donc voilà j'étais flatté donc j'en ai
parlé la direction de France 2 le seul
vrai problème de cette histoire c'est
que c'était la même heure qu'à faire
conclue moi j'étais flatté d'aller sur
rohum j'avais pas du tout envie
d'arrêter à faire conclu donc c'est sûr
que c'était pas terrible d'en obligé de
faire les deux à la fois et pour des
histoires d'emploi du temps et pour et
par respect et vis-à-vis des auditeurs
et des téléspectateurs donc France de
m'a demandé de choisir et alors là les
nuits blanches ont commencé bah oui ça a
été terrible alors après on a essayé de
de France 2 était tout à fait d'accord
pour que j'aille faire une émission sur
Europe 1 mais à un autre horaire donc on
a essayé de voir les différentes
tranches possibles mais la direction de
repas était intéressée par cette case
terriblement difficile avec une énorme
concurrence voilà donc une case que tu
connais bien
et d'autres et pas des moindres ils sont
passés donc voilà c'est compliqué c'est
pour ça que ça a été moi j'adore à faire
conclure j'ai adoré travailler sur cette
émission c'est une aventure
extraordinaire une mission novatrice des
records d'audience en six mois on est
passé de 4 à 10 et on est monté jusqu'à
24 et j'étais pas blasé parce que j'aime
apprendre je suis curieuse et
j'apprenais encore tous les jours
mais je me suis dit l'émission est
tellement formatée le concept est
tellement fort que moi je suis un petit
un petit ingrédient plus mais je pense
que l'émission elle tiendra sans moi
voilà c'est alors que là j'avais un
challenge toi
je pense que à faire conclus ça peut
devenir sans toi Europe 1 c'est toi tu
vois c'est pas pareil c'est voilà c'est
c'est ton émission c'est tonton c'est
ton truc demain on te remplace on peut
pas on doit changer toutes les missions
rien à voir
on l'a on l'a créé ensemble voilà c'est
une émission qu'on a conscience poserait
d'autres questions à Sophie